je dirais que les réactions au canada
anglais sont partagés mais si en règle
et actions majoritaire c'est de
l'incompréhension face à ce geste du
gouvernement du parti québécois les gens
pour la plupart hors québec et je suis
je souligne pour la plupart ne vois pas
en quoi le fait que quelqu'un d'autre
part porter de signes religieux
ostentatoires me blesse mois donc en
quoi ça blesse la collectivité si
quelqu'un veut protéines qui peut ainsi
djabou ainsi de suite fait que ce
sentiment est alimentée je pense par un
courant culturel plus libérale plus
anglo-saxonne comme quoi les gens
devraient être laissés agir à leur guise
et et donc l'idée d'interdire le port de
ce signe ça laisse les gens un peu plus
perplexe je dirais qu'elle l'appui
or le québec pour la charte québécoise
s'élève peut-être aux alentours de d'un
quart de la population
il suffit de décrire à quel jeu les
fêtes des critiques à l'égard de la
charte des valeurs québécoises pour
avoir des commentaires des lecteurs dans
le sens que moi je voudrais que mon
gouvernement là où j'habite fasse la
même chose il y en a qui admire le
gouvernement du québec pour ce geste là
donc il ya un vrai débat hors québec
comme au québec
j'avoue que danser dans ce genre de
débat là il ya de moins en moins de
choses qui me surprit qui me surprennent
mais s'il ya quelque chose qui me désole
s'il ya quelque chose que je regrette
c'est le réflexe hors québec de
percevoir de tels débats au québec comme
étant la réflexion d'une
nationalisme ethnique primaire veut
facile à comprendre et à dénigrer
il ya des raisons culturelles pour pour
lesquelles ce débat là se tient au
québec il y à une diversité d'opinions
au québec sur ces questions là il y à un
débat et même si jamais ce débat tirer
des conclusions que moi je regarde je
regretterais insistent toujours pour
rappeler à mes voisins que les québécois
sont nos besoins nos voisins et on est
mieux de vivre ensemble ça a l'air
angélique en mai mais c'est ça vienne
mais gatz
il y aura toujours une méconnaissance
entre le québec et les autres provinces
sur certaines questions
c'est c'est le seul fait que les gens
vivent dans leur quotidien avec leurs
voisins ils sont très peu porté à penser
aux autres mais est aussi je pense que
les grands médias sont beaucoup moins
porter a expliqué chacun chaque côté à
l'autre
les trois stars d'antan avait de très
bons journalistes à québec pour faire ce
travail là le bourgogne mettait beaucoup
plus de lumière sur ces débats là dans
nos pages mais avec les budgets avec les
coupures que l'on connaît dans les
journaux ça changeait beaucoup
donc il ya même si un explosion de
sources médiatiques
il ya peut-être moins de deux médias
prestigieuse qui passent le temps à
expliquer à ses différences et ses
nuances entre les cultures c'est la
raison pourquoi moi avec la france avec
le français que j'ai je passe le plus de
temps possible a expliqué ces choses des
deux côtés